OVERTIME WIN IN MINNESOTA
TOEWS TO MAKAR.NG ABOUT, THE
TRANSITION GAME BOTH TEAMS
POSSESS.
GABRIEL LANDESKOG, STILL BLUE
LINE.
MAKES THE READ THERE'S A RUSH
SLOT.
FLIPPED RIGHT ON NET BY  UP BACN
IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE, AND
JARRY'Y'UP.
RODRIGUES, DENIED!
LEFT PAD LINEUP HE USES
HIS POWER PLAY SPOT,
WAITING FOR SOMEONE.
IT'S RUST ON THE FOREHAND!
AND THE REBOUND SHOT ON NETMES .
TOUCHES IT BACK FOR BY HIMSELF.
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE BEST
SEQUENCE FOR JARRY.HELP.
NOW SOME SKATING ROOM FOR
CARTER!
THE SHOT RIGHT LEHKONEN.
SAVE MADE BY JARRY.
BOTH GOALTENDERS HAVE BEEN  POU.
STOPPED BY KUEMPER.O
TOOK IT TO THE BACKHAND!
THE CAGE WAS OF THE YEAR. A BLAD
CENTER IN THE NET.
>> Sean: YOU CAN SEE LANDESKOG
COUPLE OTHERS BACK, HIS A CHANC
THE BRAKE.
NEWHOOK DENIED AND THE REBOUND
SMOTHERED BY JARRY OVER THE
GLOVE OF
RANTANEN LITTLE PLAY QUICK
FROM MacKINNON.
DRAW PASS.
NICHUSHKIN GIVING SOME ROOM, MI
MARCON WITH
BURAKOVSKY.
BACK FOR MaE IT ATEL.
MATHESON'S JUST HEADING AROUND
THE BACK OF THE NET, BACK ANSWE
GOALAL JARRY.
AND